the goal of this video is simply to show
you seven AI advances that you might
have missed this week Sam Altman
recently said that in a world of AGI
everything happens much faster but as
far as I can see AI developments are
already almost impossible for a human to
keep up with so in no particular order
let's get started first video calls look
like they're about to get 3D let's take
a look at how Nvidia aerial and Nvidia
Maxine 3D running on the Nvidia Grace
Hopper Superchip can enable 3D video
conferencing on any device without
specialized software or Hardware this
brings a new dimension to video
conferencing with Maxine 3D
visualization engage with others more
directly with enhanced eye contact and
personalize your experience with
animated avatars stylizing them with
simple text prompts and it isn't just
Nvidia here's Google's new project
Starline prototype you know you were so
used to seeing a two-dimensional little
you know box and then we're connecting
like this and that feeling of being in
front of a person is now replicated in
start lines speaking of connecting the
world here is gpt4 doing geography in a
paper you might have missed from this
week the paper proves that even without
access to the internet gpt4 knows a lot
more granular detail about the world
than you might first imagine I'm not
saying it knows where you live but it's
not too far off take this example it
could recreate the Hong Kong mass
transit railway from memorization this
wasn't through using web browsing it
could recreate this diagram giving the
latitude and longitude coordinates of
each of the stations in this Transit
line obviously it's not perfect but it's
pretty incredible that it's got this
mental map of the world gpt4 can do
elevations as well and here is it trying
to recreate the Topography of the Alps
it gets pretty close one of the ways
they tested gpt4 was to ask it something
like this please provide find the
latitude longitude coordinates for the
outline of X where X was a consonant or
a river or a country as a python list of
tuples consisting of approximately 50
points arranged clockwise and they
describe how it did really well for
quite a few countries and rivers but
kind of flopped on Africa but honestly
when I read this paper I was skeptical
that gpd4 knew that little about Africa
so I gave this exact question to gpt4
with code interpreter now interestingly
it would sometimes deny that it had the
ability to do this but with enough
encouragement it outputted these
coordinates and here is the end result
in Google Earth I think that's a pretty
impressive outline obviously a few
points are a bit off like this point
here isn't really on the coast nor is
this point but it really knows the
outlines of countries continents Rivers
so I'm not sure if code interpreter had
an impact there or a model update but
the researchers kind of underplayed what
gpd4 could do by presenting this out
line of Africa now I am sure that some
of you are thinking that's not that
interesting not that impressive but
check this out in an indirect kind of
way gpt4 knows where it was made it was
able to construct a map of the
semiconductor supply chain it not only
knows about the design manufacturing
materials equipment and tools that go
into the hardware that helps make gpd4
it also knows the locations of where
this is all done and as the authors
later say looking to the future if
Frontier models Beyond Gypsy 4 continue
to advance in capabilities the
geographic knowledge and planning
abilities present in the current model
May later evolve to represent a
significant risk through misuse or
misalignment on a much less important
note did you notice how I could do this
demo without that sidebar of all my
previous chats that's because openai
have brought in this new button here
where you can hide the chats and as a
bonus some of you may not know that you
can now share a link of the chats that
you've already done just by clicking
that button to the left and as it says
messages you send after creating your
link won't be shared so if you carry on
the conversation people won't be able to
see but anyone with the URL will be able
to view the shared chat but before we
move on from open Ai and chat topt I did
find this table really quite interesting
it gives the daily average number of
visits to each of these sites along with
the visit duration and there's two
things that strike me from this table
the first is how much more popular chat
GPT is compared to Google's Bard it's
got about 15 times the number of
visitors who stay for about twice as
long but look at the Dark Horse on the
right character AI I've talked about
them a couple of times before and while
their daily average visit total isn't
too crazy look at the visit duration in
terms of grabbing people's attention and
keeping it they are truly a dark horse
next I want to briefly dip into
augmented reality we are going to be
creating our own worlds and living in
them some people like in this video
might choose to live their lives as if
they're in an animation others might see
augmented reality as a way of augmenting
their intelligence or Memory live
we don't
go my prediction would be that wearables
that resemble things like Google Glass
might flop but something like an
always-on app on your phone mediated
through GPT models could become really
popular or even enforced in certain
workplace settings all of this reminded
me of a recent video about conducting a
video interview with help from GPT 3.5
what about your development areas what
do you have identified as your greatest
and biggest Improvement areas and what
have you done to improve them so far
outside my greatest Development Area is
my communication skills I work on
improving my ability to clearly convey
my thoughts and ideas to others of
course at the moment this is only really
viable with GPT 3.5 because of inference
speed but open AI are aggressively
planning a cheaper and faster gbt4 I
wouldn't be surprised if video
interviewers soon require you to take
out any headphones although I guess with
Maxine 3D you could maintain eye contact
with the camera while you're actually
reading off a gpt4 teleprompter anyway
what about gaming this is nvidia's
neuralangelo where you can take a 2d
video and turn it into a detailed 3D
landscape with High Fidelity my first
thought turned into Imagining the kind
of things you could then bring into
games using Unreal Engine 5. this is a
recently trailered horror game Link in
the description but don't worry I'm only
going to show you two or three seconds
of it it's getting to the point where
it's quite hard to believe that this is
a game but it is and on games don't
forget this look at the realism that can
now be achieved in terms of skin texture
and movement for the final bit of AI
news that you might have missed I want
to focus on AI drug discovery
I think there's there's no question that
there is a before and after in drug
Discovery and one of them is AI Alanis
puruguzik is the director of the
University of Toronto's acceleration
Consortium which in April 2023 received
a 200 million dollar Grant to build an
ai-powered self-driving lab the
acceleration Consortium has already been
using AI to help discover molecules that
have potential drug-like traits that can
be used to develop life-saving
treatments developing a drug can be up
to a decade and this is just the
discovery piece so that process let's
say takes a year or two and we compress
it to 45 days in that case and then 30
days recently in January 2023 the
acceleration Consortium used an
ai-powered protein structure database
called Alpha fold to design and
synthesize a possible liver cancer drug
in just 30 days within two weeks we can
formulate the drug as well as some
people have done it in years suddenly AI
has surpassed any human created
algorithm AI what allows us to do is
lower the bar of what you need to do
certain things and therefore more more
people we have access to it in general
unleashing more innovation in the planet
same token someone with nefarious
intentions could unleash very dangerous
deadly chemicals on the world absolutely
I am an optimist but I'm also aware of
these pitfalls that very soon will face
us and videos like that are why I agree
with samuelman when he says a much
faster rate of change is his single
highest confidence prediction about what
a world with AGI in it will be like I
follow AI news full-time and can barely
keep up so I can only imagine what the
situation will be like when we get full
AGI but until the very last moment that
it's humanly possible to keep up with
the news I will try so thank you so much
for watching to the end and have a
wonderful day